هذه الرياضه تسمى رياضه الرمايه على ظهر
الخيل وهي رياضه تاريخيه يعود عمرها الى
مئات السنين كانت تمارس قديمه كرياضات
حربيه والان نمارسك الرياضات ونشارك فهم
في بطولات سواء محليه او دوليه
عن الفارسه نورا الجبر كارثه ومدربه
معتمده في مجال الرمايه على ظهر الخير
والتقاط
منذ ان كنت في التاسع من عمري في شواطئ
مدينه الخبر في دوله السعوديه من هناك
ابتدات طبعا رحله حبي للخيل وبعدها طبعا
دخلت الى معاهد مختصه في تعليم الفروسيه
ومن ثم طبعا تطورت المهارات تدريجيا من
مهاره الرمايه على ظهر الخيل والتقاط
الاوتاد وتعلم فنون السيف
كمواطنين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
علاقتنا بالخيل العربيه هي علاقه وطيده
يعني منذ ان بدا العرب ظهورهم على هذه
الجزيره وهم متعلقين بالخيل التعلق
مميز تحديدا عامله كفرد من الاسره يعني لا
ننظر له نظره حيوان
مجال الفروسيه ما كان هو التحدي بحد ذاته
قد ما كان دخولي في المهارات من على ظهر
الخيل هي كانت التحدي الفعلي يعني كانت
شبه منعدمه بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالنسبه للفتيات طبعا مش لكونها ممنوعه قد
ما انها كانت جديده على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كنت اواجه صراحه تحديات في البحث
عن المعلومه لان كانت اجتهادات شخصيه بحثه
واضطريت طبعا اني اسافر الى الخارج حتى
احصل على المعلومات المتعلقه في تعلم
الرمايه على ظهر الخيل ومن ثم احضار هاي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الحمد لله
بس انا الحمد لله انا وزميلتي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه كاول فارسات للمنتخب
السعودي الالتقاط الاوتاد في دوله الاردن
كانت البطوله الكبرى النسائيه وكانت
مشاركات من اكثر من 11 دوله في هذه
البطوله الحمد لله حققنا مركز زميل اللهم
لك الحمد في اول مشاركه المشاركات او التي
تعلمنا هذه المهاره مؤخرا ازدادت بشكل
ملحوظ وهذا الشيء الحمد لله مؤشر جيد في
مجال الروسيه
[موسيقى]
جميل لما الانسان يجد له مهاره او يجد له
هوايه يطورها وينميها ويقضي وقته في تعلم
المزيد منها لان سبحان الله لما تدخل
الفتاه دائما في مجال الرمايه ظهر الخيل
دائما تحاول تعلم المهارات التي تدليها
انا دائما اقول للمراه العربيه والمراه
السعوديه انت قويه استثمري وقتك في المكان
الصحيح انا عمري ما تخيلت اني اكون رامي
على ظهر الخيل ولا اتقن اي مهاره من على
ظهر الخير لكن سبحان الله جربت تعلمت
واتقنت ومثل ما انا اتقنت اعتقد ان الجميع
يستطيع